well Hamlin's survival in that moment
can be attributed in part to the very
quick reaction of the medical staff on
the field who knew to start CPR Victoria
Saha spent the day with Community
Ambulance and learned any bystander can
perform hands-only CPR in any situation
from concussions to Cardiac Arrest
Community Ambulance is in contact with
the Las Vegas Raiders to respond and
react immediately once they arrive on
scene they're going to to check for
alertness try to get something out of
them simultaneously we're looking for
any signs of breathing as well as
checking for a pulse immediately when we
don't recognize that mind you that's all
taking seconds we're immediately going
to begin CPR go right to that center of
the chest that's right where the heart's
at if I'm doing it deep and effective
compression I'm ultimately taking the
blood from the heart and I'm moving that
blood from the heart through the entire
body to the brain back to the heart well
I'm gonna go try it take your other hand
interlock fingers and then with the heel
of your dominant hand go ahead and begin
those compressions so my dominant hand
does a lot of the work along with my
upper body correct keep your arms
straight upper body is going to do it
what I learned was you need to do those
compressions 100 times per minute then
an AED machine is used while you're
doing chest compressions I'm taking the
pads off I'm placing the pads on the
patient
as AED has instructed me to do
I'm still working around you
and we're still doing effective chest
compressions
from there the AED will give us
instructions at some point it'll tell us
to stop CPR while it analyzes the heart
rhythm at that point we'll stop
and then it'll advise whether a shock is
delivered or to continue CPR the goal
and the message that we want to tell
everybody is go learn hands-only CPR if
you have the time and you have the
ability and you have the access take a
full CPR course it dives into a lot of
those various scenarios of course this
is just a glimpse of what goes into CPR
to learn more about classes available in
our area we're going to have a full list
up on our website at 8newsnow.com
Victoria saham 8 News Now
so we can also tell you that Community
Ambulance remains in contact with the
NFL to review any safety for calls